The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And so today we have
Ravi , who is I guess a
performance engineer at VMware,
where he basically
looks at how to get really good
performance in many, many
different things in VMware.
So Ravi is an MIT undergrad.
I guess a long time ago.
RAVI SOUNDARARAJAN: Yeah, '92.
PROFESSOR: '92.
There you go.
And then he got his PhD from
Stanford and end up in VMware
looking at a lot of interesting
performance stuff.
So today, he's going to give us
a kind of a bird's eye view
of how these kind of
technologies, what you guys
are learning, is useful and
how it's used in industry.
OK, Ravi.
Take over.
RAVI SOUNDARARAJAN: First
question, can
everybody hear me?
And is the mic on?
OK.
Good.
I have a bit of a sore throat.
So I'm sorry if you
can't hear me.
The other thing I want to say
is I'm actually really glad
you're here.
Because I remember very
distinctly in 1990 when I was
an undergrad, I was
taking 6.111.
And I had a bug in
my final project.
It just wasn't working.
And I was going to skip
the lecture that day.
But I was like, whatever,
I'll go.
So went to the lecture.
Turns out Don Troxell pointed
out something in that lecture.
I was like, that's my problem.
And I went back, fixed it.
Everything worked.
And I was very happy.
I don't think that's going
to happen here.
But it would be nice
if it did.
So that's cool.
So instead of just talking
about what a performance
engineer does, I would--
I'll just--
Power is coming in.
But--
Oh, there it is.
Perfect.
So instead of just talking
about what performance
engineering is about.
I just wanted to go through 10
bugs that I've actually been
involved in.
And hopefully, they'll be
interesting to you.
Because each one of them
was interesting to me.
So let's start out with--
I just wanted to start
this out with a bang.
So for dramatic effect
everybody read
through this slide.
It's basically an email thread
from one of my colleagues.
And raise your hand
when you're done.
So I'll know when you're done.
OK.
Anyway, so the point of this is
that his question ended up
being, why is the percent lock
time in the database
increasing despite a lighter
load for the thing that uses
that database?
Now, if you're like me, you
read this email, and your
first question is what the
hell is he talking about?
So that's why titled this
slide like that.
So let's actually deconstruct
what, a, that email meant.
And, b, what it meant to me.
So in order to do that, I want
to first talk about the system
that he was talking about and
help describe what the actual
problem he was seeing was.
So here we have a standard
multi-tier set up.
What we've got is that we've
got a server, which is our
middleware server.
And it talks to a database.
And then we have a bunch of
hosts on the other end.
Those are labeled by agent,
HAL, whatever.
Anyway, those are hosts running
virtual machines.
And here's the setup.
You've got a client.
And that client issues
a command to
this middleware server.
And that middleware server tries
to figure out what host
or what virtual machine
needs to be contacted.
So the middleware goes
ahead and does that.
And it performs an operation
on that host.
And after performing the
operation, it then archives
some of the information that
it gained to the database.
And once it archived the
information to the database,
it went ahead and notified the
client that the operation
itself was done.
Fairly simple.
Send a request to a server.
Server contacts some
other host.
Host comes back to the server
and says it's done.
Server persists information to
the database and then notifies
the client everything is done.
So the actual problem that my
colleague was seeing was, he
was sending less and less load
to this middleware server,
which therefore means that less
and less goes to the host
and less and less goes
to the database.
However, the percent of
time spent in the
database was higher.
So despite a lighter load and
less stuff going to the
database, the percent
of time spent in the
database was higher.
Probably, all of you are smart
enough to know what the actual
problem is.
But we'll go through
it step by step.
So the deal is this.
The first thing I did is I
examined the amount of time
that each lock was held for
each of these different
operations.
And what I did was I varied
the load just as
my colleague did.
And what you see are six
different lines.
On the x-axis is each of the
different locks that we
acquire in our system.
And on the y-axis is the latency
of those locks in
milliseconds.
And basically, the
axis for this--
the legend for this chart says
Locked-4, which means a
certain type of load, all the
way down to Locked-128.
OK.
And the deal is that when you
have lock-128, what that
indicates is that there's
128 hosts per thread.
Which, take my word for it, that
means that you've got a
lighter load.
So basically, the lowest
line in the legend is
the lightest load.
And the highest line in the
legend is the highest load.
And as you can see, although
it's a little bit obscured in
this chart, the bottom line is
that this is about time you're
spent holding a lock.
In this chart, lock-4 indicates
a heavy load.
Lock-128 indicates
a lighter load.
And what this chart indicates
is that, in fact, you are
spending more time in the locks
with a heavier load,
lock-4, than you are with a
lighter load, lock-128.
So the latency prologue is
higher with a higher load,
which is totally reasonable.
And it turns out that if we
translate my colleague's
question into reality, what
he's asking is why is the
percent time spent in the
database higher, even though
you have a lighter load?
Well, the answer ends up being
that when you have a lighter
load, overall, you're spending
less time in locks, which
means that any time you spend
in the database, if that's a
fixed cost, is going to
be a higher percent
of the overall time.
So it turns out, there really
wasn't an issue.
There was nothing odd here.
It's exactly what you'd expect,
because the database
imposes essentially
a fixed amount
of latency per operation.
And in order to confirm that,
I also looked at the time
spent contending for locks.
So you really want a lock, but
someone else gets it instead.
And you have to wait.
And the trend is exactly
the same.
When you have a lighter load,
you end up having a much lower
overall latency.
But that just means that any
latency you spend in this
database, its percent impact
on the entire operation is
quite a bit higher.
So to take a look at this and
to do a postmortem on this
case study, his first thing was
some random email, which
kind of was nonsense.
But it was less nonsensical
once you actually tried to
understand what this
setup was.
So step one is figure out what
is the experimental setup and
what are the parameters that
are being studied.
The next thing to understand
is what's being measured?
I remember what my
colleague said.
He said the percent of time in
the database was pretty high.
Why is that?
Well, OK.
So we have to understand what
this multi-tier setup is, why
you would be going to the
database, and what it means if
the time spent in that
database is high.
And I guess the next thing you
want to do is you want to say,
well, OK, he's complaining
about lock latency.
So I must have some sort of
visibility there somewhere.
Let me go and look at the
appropriate metric to figure
out what's going on and why
time is being spent there.
And finally, it's appropriate
to-- once you've got all this
data, don't make any
assumptions--
just draw the appropriate
conclusion based on the data.
The problem is basically that
with a lighter load the impact
of that database becomes larger,
even if it were the
same under a heavier load.
Because under a heavier load
other aspects of the system
also get stressed that
don't get stressed
in a lighter load.
So, and this is basically what
I'm saying here, yeah, the
percent lock time in the
database overall is higher.
But the overall lock
time is smaller.
So everything is behaving
exactly as you would expect.
So this was one simple study
and hopefully it didn't
require any virtualization
specific knowledge.
What I'm going to do now is
go over a bunch of other
different case studies that I've
looked at and crystallize
what lessons I learned from
doing those studies.
So I guess the next case study
I want to talk about is
something that I call garbage
in, garbage out.
I think that's something
I learned on the
first day of 001.
So here's the deal.
You've got a customer.
And he wants to draw
this chart.
And this chart is basically, on
the x-axis is time and on
the y-axis is some metric.
It happens to be CPU
usage megahertz.
But it doesn't really matter.
OK.
So he wants to get this chart.
And it turns out-- if you
remember the diagram I showed
before, we have a server and a
bunch of hosts at the end.
So the client simply has to send
a request to that server.
And the server will
generate the data,
send back to the client.
And it turns out that
if any of--
all of you, I'm sure, are
familiar with Pearl, Python,
and all these different
scripted languages.
There's another one that's very
popular in the Windows
community called PowerShell.
And so it turns out that
our server has
a PowerShell interface.
You can write a PowerShell
script to get any statistic
that you want.
And then you can write that
to some database or some
spreadsheet and get
this charge.
So here's the deal.
We have a user.
And what he does, as I've
indicated at the bottom, is
that he wants to get the CPU
usage for the last hour.
So he just writes a simple
script, using PowerShell.
It doesn't really matter
what the syntax is.
But the point is,
he does what's
called a get-stats call.
And he indicates, OK, I want
this virtual machine.
I want this stat, whatever.
And then he gets his
information and
writes it to a file.
No big deal.
It's just a simple script
to get some statistics.
Now, here's what is actually
interesting.
I wrote that script
using PowerShell.
Now, let's compare a PowerShell
implementation to a
highly tuned Java implementation
of the very
same script.
Now, what I've done here is I've
shown the performance of
that very same script when
getting data for one virtual
machine, which is the first
row, six, about 40.
And then up to a little over
300 virtual machines.
Look at the scaling
of this script.
In the middle column, I have
the performance for this
PowerCLI script that I
just showed you on
the previous slide.
As you can see, it goes from a
healthy 9.2 seconds to over 43
minutes if you increase the
size of your inventory.
In contrast, if you use a
Java-based implementation, it
starts a little slower than
PowerCLI at 14 seconds.
But the scaling is
far superior.
It ends up at 50 seconds.
So the question is why?
What's different about these
scripts at scale versus when I
wrote the little toy script?
Now, to give you some color,
why this matters to someone
like me is that every once in a
while, I'll get a call from
a system admin, who wants
a very simple
script that does blah.
And they say, I wrote this
simple script in my
development environment,
and it worked fine.
But then I run it in my
production environment, and it
completely breaks.
What's going on?
So often, problems like
this actually occur.
Now I'm calling this garbage in,
garbage out, because you
can see that with PowerCLI and
Java, we're getting very
different results.
The deal is that in PowerCLI,
I wrote a very naive script.
And I'll explain how
in a moment.
And that very naive script
has not performed at all.
Whereas in Java, I wrote a
very highly tuned script.
And it ended up taking
about an order of
magnitude less time.
So garbage in, garbage out.
Good stuff in, good stuff out.
Let's try to understand why.
OK.
Here's the deal.
All of you are probably familiar
with the difference
between scripting and high level
languages, or low level
languages or whatever you
want to call them.
So the idea is that if you're
running something using a
shell script or running
Pearl, or whatever.
These things are usually
meant for ease of use.
But they're not necessarily
meant for performance reasons.
And so they hide a lot of
details from the users so that
it's easier to come to
a quick prototype.
You don't have to declare
variables.
Do all this kind of junk,
right, if you're using
scripting language.
In contrast, if you're using,
Java, C++, whatever, you have
Typesafe and all
this nonsense.
You have to worry about what
the declarations of your
variables are.
Make sure they're correct
types, et cetera.
So they tend to be more
difficult to get running.
But once you get them running,
you can use a lot of advanced
tools that just aren't
available
necessarily in toolkits.
And we're going to talk about
how this difference manifested
itself in this particular
problem.
I said that when I told the
customer to write a simple
PowerCLI script, they just
have to do one call.
Get-stat.
And here's a bunch of arguments
to tell it what
statistic it wants to grab.
It's a toolkit.
It's doing a lot of
work for you.
What's it doing for you?
Well, it turns out it's calling
our internal APIs.
Our internal APIs have
to work for a variety
of different platforms.
So they have to be incredibly
general.
Under the covers of that single
get-stat call, we have
about seven different steps
that are going on, ranging
from asking, OK, I want a stat
for a virtual machine, what
kinds of stats does that
virtual machine export?
How frequently does it update?
All kinds of information that
you probably don't really care
about if all you want
is a single stat.
But you might care about if
you're writing a production
quality script.
So the point is get-stat
does these seven calls.
And because you're using
a toolkit, it hides
them all from you.
It spares it.
It's very easy to use.
But it turns out, this is
obviously not the most optimal
way to do this.
And I illustrate that by showing
you conceptually
what's actually going on.
On the right, I guess on your
left, I've got what the
PowerCLI script was doing.
You call this get-stat call, or
whatever, and what it does
that for every virtual machine
that you want this statistic
for, it goes through and does
all these random steps that
were done that I described
in the previous slide.
Figuring out what stats are
supported, how frequently they
updated, and then actually going
and getting the stat.
It turns out, as I show on the
right, when I do this in Java,
I can take advantage of the
fact that a lot of those
things that I'm asking
about in the
toolkit, they never change.
You've got a good
virtual machine.
It supports things to
be refreshed every
20 seconds or whatever.
That never changes.
You want to find out what
statistics are supported.
Well, those never change once
you've configured it and you
don't change anything.
So why do that every
single time?
So as we show in Java, you can
pull a lot of that stuff out
of the main body of the loop.
And if you wanted information
for every VM in the system,
you only have to make one call,
as I show at the very
bottom, for every VM.
You don't have to make seven
different RPC calls.
In fact, you could further
optimize, if you really
understand the API, and collapse
a few more calls in
Java that you can't
do in the toolkit.
Because again, the toolkit's
trying to talk at a high
level, so any random dude can
actually write a script.
OK.
So the point is in this PowerCLI
world, a very simple
toolkit world, we were making
five RPC calls for every VM
that we wanted stats for.
Whereas in Java, we
made one call.
And we can even optimize
that further.
And I don't show that here.
But anyway, the bottom line is
that's why the performance of
the Java script was
so much faster.
So the idea is that with
PowerCLI what I do is I wrote
very simple, a script that
anybody could understand and
use, but it's not optimized.
I didn't utilize
multi-threading.
I didn't realize that the output
format of the data was
really, really verbose.
Again, that's the kind of
thing that if you really
understand the APIs you
can take advantage of.
I also didn't realize--
as a customer, I wouldn't have
realized that I make this one
call but it expands it to a
bunch of different network
requests that I didn't
know about.
In contrast, with Java, I was
able to take advantage of the
power of a language like Java,
where I could thread pools.
I could optimize the return
format of the data.
And I could reduce the
number of RPC calls.
I guess the analogy I would
give is if you think about
assembly code versus
compiler-generated code,
nobody here wants to sit down
and write x86 Assembly.
So, of course, you write C and
you use GCC and whatever.
But maybe there are some things
that would actually be
faster if you wrote
hand assembly.
OK.
So, first example we gave was
just understanding what on
earth the problem was.
The second example was if I
write bad code, I'm going to
usually get bad output.
In the third case, I'm going to
talk a little bit about the
design of an API.
And I'm going to motivate
that by an example.
We have an administrator
on the right hand side.
And he's talking to the
management server.
This management server is
responsible for telling that
administrator what's going in
every host in the system,
every virtual machine,
whatever.
So let's pretend that the user
wants-- so this is a
virtualized environment-- so
the idea is that the user
wants to actually access his
or her virtual machine.
They're running a Linux
virtual machine.
They want to see its console.
So they can type
at the console.
Here's how that roughly works.
They want to see the console of
the VM that I've circled.
So the way it works is that
this user talks to the
management server.
The management server locates
that virtual machine,
establishes a handshaking
connection.
And that connection
is directly given
back to that user.
So now the user can interact
directly with that virtual
machine and send commands
and do whatever.
So we've all got the setup.
Very simple.
Now here's the deal.
The problem was that our poor
little user, poor big user,
whatever, they could not start
this console when they were
managing a large number
of hosts.
To take you back to this diagram
for just a moment, on
the right hand side
of the screen, I
show a number of hosts.
And I show a number of
virtual machines.
So what I'm basically saying
is that this administrator
could not access the console of
his virtual machine as the
number of hosts increased.
There should be no link
between these two.
But there was.
So I got involved
in this problem.
And here I went to
the client folks.
And I explained the problem.
And their response was that's
obviously a server problem.
Next step, I go to
the server folks.
And they said, yeah, it's
obviously a client problem.
So then I went back and thought
a little bit more
about the architecture.
And what I knew is that whenever
the client needs to
initiate this handshake
connection, it has to spawn a
certain process.
So that process is called the
VMRC, VMware remote console.
So I talked to the client
folks again.
And said, well, I think
this is happening.
Oh, yeah, it's a VMRC problem.
OK.
So that just passes the
buck another way.
So then I talk to
the VMRC folks.
And I said, OK, I think I have
this problem with starting up.
And they said, oh, it's probably
authentication.
It's probably this.
You have to enable verbose log
in on your end host, blah,
blah, blah.
And at some point, I got
so sick of this.
I thought, well, this
is complete garbage.
I'm actually going to
take a look at this
a little more carefully.
And so, once I got involved,
I got a little bit more
information.
And the information was actually
pretty useful.
Here's the deal.
When you're starting the remote
console on one of these
virtual machines and you want
to connect, it turns out the
person that was having this
problem-- when you ask a few
more questions, you get
a few more answers.
Some of which are
actually useful.
So I said, well, if you
do this with 50 hosts,
do you see a problem?
So 50 manage hosts,
he only wants to
view one VM's console.
No problem.
Then I asked him-- and then I
actually sat at my desk, and
we reproduced this.
So then I said, let's try it
with 500 hosts, no problem.
Just a little bit slower,
but no problem.
So again, the set up is 500
different hosts, he just wants
to look at one VM.
And it's taking longer and
longer to view that one VM.
Finally, he gets
to 1,001 hosts.
And that's when the
problem occurs.
That' when he cannot
see this console.
So obviously then, you go back
and you think, well, gee, is
there some magic number of 1,000
hard coded anywhere,
such that we exceeded it, and
that was the problem.
And frankly, the answer is no.
So let's figure out actually
what did happen.
So I made a bunch of different
observations while I was
debugging this.
When you have fewer than that
magic number of 1,001 hosts,
here's what was going on.
Remember the sequence
of events.
I'm a client.
I talked to a server.
Server talks to the
virtual machine.
And then that virtual machine
and I are directly connected.
What I was noticing was that
when there were less than
1,000 overall hosts in this
setup, when I would initiate
the command for this console.
The CPU usage and memory usage
of this middle management
server would gradually increase,
and increase, and
increase until the console
would actually show up.
So you right click.
You want to pull up a console.
A little window comes up.
But it's totally blank.
And then eventually, after the
management server consumes a
lot of CPU and memory,
eventually that
console comes up.
So now your question is what's
going on that's causing the
CPU usage of this management
server.
And why is that scaling
with the number of
your virtual machines.
So the first thing I did-- so
one of the themes of this
talk, I suppose, is that there's
a lot of great tools
for performance debugging.
But sometimes there's no real
substitute for common sense
and for the things that
are easiest to do.
So the first thing I did
is I looked at the log
file of this server.
Here's the rationale.
If every time I invoke this
remote console, I'm doing more
work on the server.
First, let me just see what
that server is doing.
Now, it turns out that what I'd
noticed about the server
was that whenever the client
would contact the server and
say I want the console of this
VM, you would see a data
retrieval call from the
client to the server.
And that data retrieval call
got more and more expensive
with more hosts and
more virtual
machines in the system.
So the question that I asked
was, why on earth are we doing
some stupid data retrieval call
if all I wanted is to
say, here's a VM.
Tell me where it's located
so I can talk to it.
So it turns out--
that was problem number one.
Problem number two, that's what
happened when you had 50
hosts, 500, whatever, that you
basically spend more and more
time in this data retrieval
routine on the server.
However, once you hit that magic
number of 1,000, you
would see this call start.
But you would never
see it end.
And in fact, you wouldn't
You'd see some exceptions
somewhere.
So that to me was a clue that
I better take a look and see
what's going on at
that exception.
So here's what I did.
Unfortunately, the exception
gave me no information
whatsoever.
So I went ahead and I attached
a debugger to the server.
And when I did, I found
out that it was an
out of memory exception.
So here's the deal.
I'm a poor admin.
I send a request to
look at a console.
For some reason, some data
handshaking code takes place
between the server
and the client.
It takes longer and longer
with more hosts.
Eventually, when I have too many
hosts, that thing ran out
of memory and silently failed.
And so my client's sitting
around looking dumb with a
totally blank screen, because
it has no idea that its
request basically got denied.
So the question is why
is that happening?
And aha, this is where the
aha moment occurred.
I happen to know that one of the
reasons in our setup, that
one of the causes for this data
retrieval, is that as a
client, I want to know certain
attributes of the virtual
machine that I wanted to view.
For example, if I'm looking at
the console for a virtual
machine, I might care that that
virtual machine has a
CD-ROM connected.
And I might care if
that CD-ROM got
disconnected or whatever.
That's not something you'd
necessarily associate with a
virtual machine.
But when I go to the server to
connect to it, the server
wants to give me that
information so that the shell,
which is showing me this console
can appropriately
update if the virtual machine
gets disconnected from its
CD-ROM, whatever.
Anyway, the point is I looked at
the code that this magical
VMRC routine was doing.
And here's what it was doing.
It was saying, look,
I want to start a
remote console session.
I need certain information like
the CD-ROM connectivity.
I'm going to go ahead and get
that information for every
host and every virtual machine
in the system.
And then once that's done, I'll
go ahead and display the
console for this one virtual
machine that I care about.
Well, this is clearly
just a stupid idea.
So I called the guy up and I
said, you realize this is
stupid idea.
And he said, well, why?
It's not that expensive.
Is it?
And I was like, OK, we need
to have a long discussion.
And bring a priest in here.
But that's a terrible idea.
So what we ended up doing is--
And so now--
OK, so that's the problem.
The problem is we drew a
huge data retrieval.
None of which we need.
Now why this 1,001 host thing?
Here's the deal.
It turns out that in our code,
we had-- for old style
clients, of which this was an
old style client-- we had a
restriction.
We said if you need to serialize
more than 200
megabytes worth of data, we're
not going to handle that.
We're just going to fail.
It turns out once we got 1,001
hosts, we slightly exceeded
that 200 megabyte buffer size,
we silently erred with an out
of memory exception.
And we never returned
to the client.
And everybody was unhappy.
So it had nothing to do
with 1,000 hosts.
It has to do with the
amount of data
you're actually sending.
So luckily, there were several
different fixes.
So I told the VMRC folks, the
guy that wrote this thing, I
said, please, under no
circumstances, should you get
information for every single
host if you only want it for
this one guy.
That's a terrible idea.
And then I went back to the
server folks, and I said, you
have to admit--
first of all, you have
to fail correctly.
And second, you have to admit
sensible error messages,
because this should not take the
kind of expertise that it
took to figure out.
And thankfully, this made
actually a pretty huge
difference.
So that was kind of cool.
So the lessons that I took away
from this is if you're
going to create an API, create
an API that's very difficult
to abuse and very easy to use.
Not the opposite.
These poor VMRC folks, it's
like a three line piece of
code to get information
for every VM.
It's like eight or nine lines
to get information
for just that VM.
But those five lines make a
boatload of difference.
The other thing is
that this was an
entirely internal customer.
In other words, it's just
another group within VMware.
Imagine you're some external guy
that's using the same API.
You're screwed.
So we have to be better at
educating the people that are
using our API.
And don't just throw it
over the fence and
say here's an API.
Deal with it.
There needs to be some
interaction between them to
make sure that this is the
right API for its job.
This is the next case study
I want to talk about.
This one actually was found by
a colleague of mine, who I'm
going to abbreviate as RM.
Very interesting example.
For those of you that took
the class last year,
I'm recycling it.
But it's a good example,
so no worries.
So here's the deal.
You've got a benchmark.
And I've got two builds of
a piece of software.
When I run the benchmark
against that piece of
software, in case a, I was
getting a throughput of 100
operations per minute.
In case b, I was getting
half the throughput.
And what was the difference
between those builds?
Well, the first build, the
faster build, was a 32-bit
executable running on
64-bit hardware.
While in the second case, it
was a 64-bit executable
running on 64-bit hardware.
Now if you're like me--
which hopefully you're not--
but if you're like me, you
think yourself, well, there
shouldn't be much difference
between 32-bit and 64-bit.
In fact, 64-bit should be a
lot faster for a lot of
reasons you're going to
learn about in 004.
So the question is
what's going on?
I can distinctly remember when
this check-in was done,
somebody said, oh, we're making
the switch over, but it
shouldn't be a big deal.
And foolishly, like a moron, I
actually believed that person.
Very bad idea.
So this came back to haunt
us for three months.
So what's the deal?
Remember, a 32-bit executable
running on 64-bit code was
faster than a 64-bit executable
running on a 64-bit
application.
So the first thing we do--
first of all, you've got
to find the right tool
for the right job.
In this case, we use a profiling
tool called Xperf.
Xperf is a very powerful
profiler, kind of like Vtune,
or Valgrind, or Quantifier, or
a lot of the other tools
you've used.
The nice thing is it's
built into the OS.
It runs on Windows 2008.
And it's a sampling based
profiler that has a lot of
pretty cool attributes.
If you have Windows 2008, I
think you ought to just go and
download it.
It's free.
And play with it.
This gives a lot of information
like stack traces,
caller/callee information,
et cetera.
It's potentially the perfect
tool for this kind of job.
What kind of output
does it show?
In this case, remember
the setup.
The setup is I run build A. And
I'm getting twice as much
throughput as running build B.
So let's take a look at the
CPU usage, just as a first cut
to see what's going on.
In the 64-bit case, which
is what I showed here.
I showed the output of this
Xperf for 64-bit.
What you can see, x-axis
is just time.
And y-axis is CPU usage.
It's totally saturated.
In the 64-bit case, we're
completely saturated.
Take my word for it, in the
32-bit case, you're not.
And this accounts for
the difference.
So now let's dig deeper and find
out why we're seeing this
difference.
So first, we look at the
sampling profiler.
Now there's a lot of perils of
using sampling profilers.
In this particular case,
here's the deal.
I've got a process.
And that process spawns
a bunch of threads.
In this particular view, what
you're seeing is where is the
time being spent in
this process.
And as you can see, most of the
time is spent at the root,
which kind of makes sense.
Because everything in some sense
is a child of the root.
But the first thing our poor
process does, it spawns a
bunch of child threads.
So clearly, all of the time is
essentially going to be spent
in the routine that calls all
of these threads, because
that's the first entry point.
But unfortunately, that's
remarkably unhelpful.
So the deal is we have to dig
deeper and find out, where is
this time actually
being spent.
So like I said, just to kind of
reiterate the point that I
made on the previous slide.
The point is that your
entry point is
spawning all the threads.
And if that's kind of the
starting point for accounting,
you're not going to get any help
if you're just looking at
that starting point.
You have to dig a little
bit deeper.
And so what I'm basically trying
to say, is that even
though this thing records
stack traces, this stack
happens to be the most
popular stack.
But it's not actually
the problem.
Because it's the most popular,
because that's
where everybody starts.
So all of the time that
is charged gets
charged to that stack.
We have to look a little
bit deeper.
So in order to look a little bit
deeper, let's think about
the problem in a slightly
different way.
Suppose I've got my root.
That's where everything
starts.
That's where all the threads
are spawned, whatever.
And suppose I have three paths
to a tiny little function at
the very end.
Maybe I'm spending all
of my time in the
path that I've indicated.
But the problem is that--
suppose you're spending all of
your time in that tiny little
function, and suppose it's
equally spent among these
other three paths.
Well, it's not any path that's
kind of screwed up.
It's that that tiny function
is kind of messed up.
So you got to figure out why are
you spending time in that
tiny function?
And is there something that
you can do to fix that?
So let's look from the
opposite perspective.
Let's look at the caller view.
In this case, what I did was I
looked at a bunch of different
routines, a bunch of
these different
so-called tiny functions.
And I looked at what was calling
those tiny functions.
It turns out that here's a call,
ZwQueryVirtualMemory
some tiny function.
It happens to be-- it turns out
that we're spending, as it
indicates, 77% of our time
in this tiny function.
And just to emphasize that
this is not being
called from the root.
So you don't see it from
your first glance.
You can see that the number of
times this tiny function was
called from the root is 0.34%.
So if you were just looking from
the root and trying to
figure out what's being
called from the root.
It would be totally useless.
Instead, you have
to dig deeper.
And see all the different
functions
that are being called.
And find out where they're
being called from.
So we know that this function,
ZwQueryVirtualMemory, is
taking like 70% of the CPU,
which is an enormously large
amount of CPU.
We also know what's calling
it are these two
routines right here.
This thing, this magical
thing called
RTDynamicCast and RTtypeid.
So it turns out we have two
paths that are going to this
tiny function.
And those two paths comprise
most of the calls
to this tiny function.
And it turns out we're spending
a boatload of time in
this tiny function.
So let's dig deeper and find
out what on earth these two
routines are.
What is RTtypeid?
What is RTDynamicCast,
whatever?
So let's first look
at RTDynamicCast.
What I show here--
in contrast to the
previous view.
The previous view said, I
have a tiny function.
What are the people
that call me?
Let's look at the reverse.
Let's go and start at one of
these two routines, RTtypeid.
And figure out what it's calling
that is spending so
much time, and ultimately
leads to us calling that
ZwQueryVirtualMemory
or whatever.
And as you can see, this
RTtypeid, it calls two
functions primarily.
One is incrementing a
reference counter.
And the other is decrementing
a reference counter.
Now you're thinking to yourself,
incrementing a
reference counter, decrementing
a reference
counter should be very simple,
very low CPU, and basically
should cost you nothing.
And all of those three
assumptions are dead wrong,
unfortunately.
So let's try to understand
a little bit as
to why that's happening.
Turns out RTtypeid is used in
order to figure out the C++
type of an object.
So we're trying to figure
this out on the fly.
And as I said, it's kind of
mystifying that this routine,
which calls our tiny function,
that you're spending 39%
overall in this routine
in that tiny function.
So let's figure out what's
going on by looking at a
simple example, which
would be IncRef.
So it turns out if you're
looking at this code, the
dreadful line is the fact that
we're doing const type info
reference tinfo equals
typeid of *this.
This is basically, you have to
call RTtypeid to get this kind
of information.
And in order to do that, you
need some runtime type
information.
This runtime type information
has some pointers
associated with it.
So here's the deal.
Whether I'm running a 32-bit--
Remember, we even forgot the
original problem, which is,
gee, I'm 32-bit, 64-bit
executable--
sorry 32-bit executable
on 64-bit hardware.
We were slower than a 64-bit--
we were faster than a 64-bit
executable on 64-bit hardware.
Let's try to figure out why.
Well, remember, every time I
increment or decrement a
reference counter, I get some
type information by consulting
this runtime type information.
It's got a bunch of pointers.
When I run a 32-bit executable
on 64-bit hardware, those
pointers are just raw
32-bit pointers.
You just look them up,
and you're done.
In 64-bit, pretty much the
only difference is that
instead of those pointers being
actual pointers, they're
32-bit offsets.
So you take the offset, you add
it to the base address of
the DLL of the executable or
whatever, where that runtime
typeid call is being made.
And then you're done.
Once you've added that offset,
you get a 64-bit pointer.
You look up that 64-bit pointer,
everybody's happy.
So here's the deal.
Remember, we said
32-bit's faster.
32-bit is just a pointer
look up.
And then you're done.
64-bit's slower.
It's a pointer look up-- and
it's an addition plus a
pointer look up.
So I pause, because you're
thinking to yourself, an
addition plus a pointer look up
versus a pointer look up.
Does that mean that
addition is slow?
That sounds really stupid.
And by the way, it
is really stupid.
It's not true.
So the deal is this.
It's not that addition
to create a
64-bit pointer is slow.
The deal is that-- remember
this 2-step process.
You find out the base
address of a module.
And you add this offset
to that base address.
Determining that base address
is really, really slow.
It turns out you have to call
a bunch of different random
routines that have to walk the
list of loaded modules.
And you're doing this
every single time
you call this routine.
And if you increment a reference
whenever you do a
memory allocation, you can
imagine that this is going to
consume a lot of CPU.
So it turns out, this is
what's actually slow.
And remember, that we started
this off a little by saying,
oh, we've got this
weird function,
ZwQueryVirtualMemory, which
seems to be being called a lot
from a bunch of different
places.
The reason it's called a lot
is because all of these
routines to get typeid
information are
calling this routine.
So there's actually
two solutions.
And you can look on this blog
to actually figure out that
this is a known problem that
Microsoft eventually fixed.
And it turns out, that the two
solutions end up being that
you can either statically
compute that base address so
you're not constantly
relooking it up
every single time.
But there's actually a much
simpler and stupider solution,
which is, use the latest runtime
library where they
have actually fixed
this problem.
So just to summarize
what was going on.
We were CPU saturated.
We looked from the top down.
We didn't notice anything.
We looked from the bottom up.
And we noticed that some bottom
was being called a lot.
We figured out where that bottom
was being called by
looking at caller/callee
views.
Once we figured out where it
was being called, we then
tried to figure out why that
thing was being called.
And then we fixed the problem.
So to me, I guess the take-home
lesson from this is
that when that developer said
to me, three months before
this whole debacle started,
he said, oh, yeah, we're
switching from say
32 to 64-bit.
That's not a big deal.
You can't really take that stuff
at face value, because a
lot of little things
can really add up.
And we could never have really
guessed that this would happen
beforehand.
So that's four.
Let me go over another one.
Memory usage.
So excessive--
I'm sure actually all of you
know that memory usage is a
big problem.
Your application is going to
slow down if you're inducing a
lot of paging.
And at least in 32-bit Windows,
if you exceed two
gigabytes for the process that
you're running, the process is
just going to crash.
So you clearly do care
about memory usage.
And I want to differentiate
between memory leaks and
memory accumulation.
You're wondering why would
a process take up two
gigabytes of memory.
Well, one is that maybe
you have a leak.
You allocate something.
You don't remove it.
That might just be
an accumulation.
You allocate something somewhere
in your code, you
actually are freeing it.
But the trouble is that routine
never gets called,
because in your code logic you
never take the time to think
and say, OK, can I actually get
rid of this at this point.
And that's what I'm going to
call a memory accumulation.
There's a lot of different tools
out there to analyze
memory usage.
And the sad part about this is
that almost none of them work
for the particular example that
we have, because they
just didn't scale very well.
It's fine if you've got your
toy, stupid little application
that does addition in a loop.
Not so fine if you've got an
enterprising middleware
application.
So we ended up, despite all
the tools that we have
available, we ended up having
to write our own.
I didn't do this,
a colleague did.
But anyway, I guess
that distinction
doesn't really matter.
But anyway, the point is that
you do a lot of what these
other tools do.
But you do it special
to your environment.
In this case, we just hooked a
lot of the calls to malloc.
And we figure out what
pointers are live.
And then we do stuff
from there.
This is how normal tools work.
And of course, this can be
unusably slow if you do a ton
of allocations.
For example, if you're doing
millions of allocations per
second, you can imagine you're
calling this kind of routine,
which itself--
if it only has a 10x overhead
over a call without that,
you're slowing down your program
by 10x for every
single memory allocation.
That means performance depends
on how many allocations you
do, which is really bad.
And just to illustrate what
I mean by a leak.
My definition is basically
that you've got
this routine, foo.
And it mallocs some data.
But it returns without
freeing that data.
And nowhere else in the
code log did you
actually have a free.
That's an actual memory leak.
An accumulation would be if you
have some free somewhere.
But it's never actually
called.
So a lot of the code that we
write happened-- at least in
the past, it's changing-- but
a lot of it happened to be
written in C++.
And all of you, I guess assume,
you know about new and
delete and all those kinds of
things that we do in C++.
And it turns out, that those
things are notoriously bad for
assigning memory leaks.
So instead, what people
typically do is they use
reference counted objects.
So every time you use something
you increment some
reference count.
And every time you
delete it, you
decrement a reference count.
And when the decremented
reference count is zero it
automatically gets deleted.
Now of course, this only
solves an actual leak.
It doesn't solve an
accumulation.
So here was the problem
that I noticed.
That was all kind of setup, just
saying what's a memory
leak, what's an accumulation,
why is memory a problem.
Let's get to actually why
it was a problem.
I had this issue.
I have our little server
application.
And it's running out of memory
after several hours.
Now I used Purify on a much,
much smaller setup.
It was about 1/100 the size of
the actual setup, because
larger than that, Purify would
crash, because it would run
out of memory.
Because by the way, to track
all the memory references,
it's got to allocate memory,
which ends up being a
nightmare of unprecedented
proportions.
So the deal was, was that I
couldn't really detect this
leak very easily.
So what I did was I examined
the memory that was in use.
Essentially, what I'm trying to
say is that, there wasn't
so much a leak as there
was an accumulation.
Accumulation again being
a logical problem.
Well, yeah, all of my code
is written correctly.
But it's just that free
call is never called.
So I examined the memory in use
and I localized it to one
operation that whenever we did
it, memory would increase.
So since doing it only once,
there's a lot of noise.
What I did was I said, well, OK,
why don't I just do this
operation hundreds of times
at the same time.
Because then, if I see some
allocation that's 100x from
before I started this
I can know that this
was actually a problem.
And that's exactly what I did.
I had this issue where
something was being
allocated 64 bytes.
Now 64 bytes is so small that
it's pretty much in the noise.
But if you do it a hundred
times, and you're
seeing 6,400 bytes.
Then you do it a thousand
times and you
see 64 times 1,000.
Then it becomes something
easily that
you can then track.
Once I noticed that this
particular piece of data was
being allocated like this, I
went through and I realized
that this actually was--
it was an accumulation
and not a leak.
So someone would allocate
something whenever an incoming
message came in.
And there was a free somewhere,
but it was never
being called.
So the lesson that I learned
from this is that in a lot of
situations with performance
debugging, it's very helpful
to try to find a problem--
in order to try to find a
problem, it's very helpful to
magnify it and make
it a lot worse.
If you think something is
problematic in the network,
slow down your network
if that's an option.
If you think something has a
problem with memory usage,
either do something like what
I've described here.
Or maybe reduce the
amount of memory.
When I was in graduate school,
we were working on a cache
coherence protocol.
And I'm going to spare you
a lot of the details.
But here's the thing.
We basically stored a linked
list for every data in memory.
And we had to make sure that
that linked list was rock
solid no matter what the size
of the inventory was.
And if you exceeded the
linked list, you'd
store stuff in disk.
So what we did to magnify any
possible bugs was we created
it so that you could
make a linked list
of at most one item.
That way no matter what you
did it would force you to
overflow and go into disk.
And that was a great way to
test a lot of overflow
conditions that in practice
would never have occurred.
Because we do the engineering
thing, figure out the
capacity, double it, and hope
that nothing happens.
So it's good to exaggerate
edge conditions.
So that's one memory
analysis problem.
Here's another one.
Here's the deal.
You've got a user and they're
using this middleware server.
And they complain that with
time it gets slower, and
slower, and slower.
And if you look at
all of the--
if you look at CPU network and
disk, you see that nothing is
being saturated there.
But if you look at memory,
it's increasing pretty
dramatically.
And at some point, it increases
so dramatically that
the server application
crashes.
So first thing, let's actually
look at the memory utilization
and see the timeline.
What I show here is I show
versus time, I show a chart of
something in Windows that's
called private bytes.
Essentially, think of
that as memory.
What you see is that memory is
growing slowly, whatever.
But at some point, near the very
end, near when the server
crashes, it starts growing at
a really, really fast clip.
Now remember, I call
this private bytes.
What that essentially is, in
this particular case, it's
Windows giving a process
some amount of memory.
It's not necessarily what
the process or what the
application is requesting.
The application will request
some amount.
And Windows will give
it this much.
Well, Windows keeps giving it
more and more and more.
And it eventually just runs
out of memory to give.
So the reason I made the
distinction between something
that an application and
something Windows is giving it
is that I, as an application,
might be asking for
four bytes at a time.
Four bytes, four bytes,
whatever.
But what if Windows has this
problem where, whenever you
allocate-- it doesn't, but
suppose it does-- suppose that
every time you ask for four
bytes, it says, well, you know
what, I'm just going to give you
16 bytes because that's my
smallest increment of memory.
You can imagine if I keep asking
for 4 and it's dumb
enough to give me 16 every time,
we're going to see a
huge expansion of memory, even
though I, as an application,
didn't ask for that much.
So it's important to keep these
distinctions in mind.
So the point is what was
happening in this case, was my
server's going fine, fine, and
fine, until near the very end
where it starts increasing in
memory use at such a dramatic
rate, that it eventually
crashes.
So the first thing I did--
We just talked a
lot about these
reference counted objects.
The fact that I keep track
of whenever something is
allocated and whenever something
is not being looked
at anymore.
When it's not being looked
at anymore, I go
ahead and remove it.
If you look at the reference
counted objects, they were
pretty flat until you get to
the very end of the run,
exactly the same as when the
memory was increasing.
And it turns out, I've
highlighted a few of these,
and they ended up being--
it doesn't matter what they
specifically were-- but in
this case, they ended up being
related to threads, and
mutexes, and stuff associated
with keeping track of what was
going on in the system.
So some thread-related
objects were
increasing for some reason.
Now turns out thread state in
some sense is very cheap.
So just because these guys were
increasing, it doesn't
really explain why we're
dramatically
increasing in memory.
But I'll tell you what
does explain it.
If you take a look at a
different attribute, which is
these are the total number of
threads in our system, we have
a static pool of threads.
And whenever a work item comes
in, we allocate a thread.
Whenever that work
item is done, we
deallocate the thread.
So we keep it to a
minimal number.
And it turns out,
we had a cap.
We said, OK, I'm going to allow
at most 20 operations to
occur in flight.
Anything beyond 20, I'm going
to queue it up in memory.
And we'll deal with it later.
Here's the deal.
What you see when you look at
the number of threads being
used is that--
it's the bottom chart,
unfortunately, it's a little
hard to see.
But the point is it goes up and
down, up and down, up and
down with time.
So stuff gets allocated.
Stuff gets used.
Stuff gets removed.
But then when you get to the
very end, you see this
monotonic increase in the number
of threads being used.
It never goes down.
And at some point, you hit the
point where all of the threads
that you've preallocated
are completely taken.
You obviously can't allocate
any more threads.
So every incoming request,
you go ahead and queue.
This was the root
of the problem.
The root of the problem is
that in this particular
situation, each of the times
that it was increasing was
because there was again
an uncaught exception.
That uncaught exception resulted
in a thread not being
deallocated.
At some point, we ran
out of threads.
And every single request that
came in was being allocated in
memory and waiting around for
a thread to become available
before it could be finished.
Well, if no threads are
available, these things can
never get pulled
off the queue.
You see a monotonic increase
in the amount of memory.
And you eventually die.
And so, it's actually
a correctness issue.
Why are you not catching
exceptions properly?
And why are you not recovering
properly from them.
But interestingly, it manifested
itself in a
performance issue.
So in each of these cases,
what we've done, is we've
looked at customized profiler
instead of a tool that we
might have gotten, Purifier,
Valgrind, or whatever--
it's nice that it's tailored
to our application.
And we can make it as
arbitrarily fast, because it
understands what our application
is doing.
And it also-- the other nice
thing about this is this can
be run in production
environments.
If you write your own tool,
and a customer calls and
complains, you can just say, oh,
just twiddle this knob and
you're done.
That's kind of convenient.
But of course, the disadvantage
is that now you
have to-- whenever you rewrite
your code or do a new rev, or
whatever, you have
to make sure that
these tools work right.
And you have to recompile
the code.
If you have something like
Purifier, Quanitify, in a lot
of situations, you can run with
some sort of preexisting
binary-- sometimes,
not always.
You can run it without
having to recompile.
And that can be very
convenient.
So I don't know.
I was kind of stuck for what a
lesson this was besides common
sense is useful.
So I just said memory profiling
is pretty critical.
Don't ignore that when you're
writing your applications.
And I think I also want
to point out that--
I didn't put this here.
But you might think that when
you're using a garbage
collected language, like
something like Java, that
these problems go away.
But they actually don't.
The problem is actually now
memory allocations and
deallocations are more
hidden from you.
So you have to be a little bit
more careful about how you
analyze them.
Case study number seven.
So we've looked a lot of things
related to CPU usage.
We've looked at a lot of things
related to memory.
Now let's look a little
bit at the network.
Here was the problem.
I have a user, our
Canonical admin.
The user wants to perform an
operation on some virtual
machine somewhere.
Remember the flow.
Issue request, it goes
to some server.
The server goes to the host
where that VM is.
Does some operation,
comes back.
So this user wants to
perform an operation
on a virtual machine.
I had setup A, In setup A, this
operation end to end took
about eight seconds.
Fine.
That doesn't mean much until you
compare to setup B, where
it took twice the
amount of time.
It took 16 seconds,
not 8 seconds.
So now the question you're
asking yourself is what's the
difference between
setups A and B.
In setups A and B, the only
difference is that this middle
server is a different
version number.
But everything else is
exactly the same.
So with this different version
you somehow manage to make
your performance twice as bad,
which is a really bad thing.
We got to get to the
bottom of that.
And in addition, it's not like
it was some random thing that
happened once.
It happened every single time.
So now, let's take a look
at what was going on.
So again, a lot of times, I
tend to do things in a top
down manner, where I say what's
the easiest information
to collect.
And then, OK.
What's more difficult, what's
more difficult?
And finally, if you have to use
really industrial strength
tools, you use them.
But it might not be necessary.
In this case, my first thing
was just to use logging and
try to figure out where
time was being spent.
Remember, we've got a client
talking to a server, talking
to an end host.
In this case, the latency
imposed by that client was
exactly the same in
these two setups.
So that's not where this eight
seconds is being lost.
The amount of time being claimed
by the server was
exactly the same.
I'm a client.
I go to a server.
It then goes to a host.
However, the time spent on
the host was different.
That's where all of the
time was being spent.
Now, you're probably looking
at-- well, you may not be.
But I'll tell you to look now.
We had setup A. Setup A was a
client and the server were
each at some version number.
And the host was at the
same version number.
In setup B, the client and the
server were at a different
version number with respect
to the host.
But we just said all of
the time is being
spent in the host.
So why is that going on?
And this is where understanding
the architecture
is important.
It turns out in this case, the
first thing that happens when
you have a difference in version
number is that the
server helpfully talks to the
end host and says you know
what, you're in a different
version number.
So let me give you some code
to run, because you're in a
different version number.
So in fact, even though the host
is at the same version
number, there's a small shim
running on that host that
makes up for the fact
that it's not at the
same version number.
So now let's analyze this host
and figure out where is this
time being spent.
I did a little bit more
logging on the host.
The reason I did this, because
a lot of the standard tools
that you might use, like gprof
or whatever, these things
didn't exist.
We have our own kernel.
Which therefore, we have our
own tools and our own
nightmares, and headaches
associated with it.
So we had to use these tools
instead of commercially
available tools.
When you use these tools,
we ended up
narrowing down the time.
Here's what goes on.
I'm a client.
And I talk to the server.
The server talks to an
agent on the host.
It says, agent, this is
what I want to do.
The agent then talks to the
hardware abstraction layer and
says, dude, this is
what I want to do.
The hardware abstraction layer
comes back to the agent and
says, done.
Agent goes back to the server.
Sever goes back to the client,
blah, blah, blah.
It turns out that this
interaction on the host
between the agent that accepted
the call from the
server and the hardware
abstraction layer, that was
where all of the time
was being spent.
It was 10 milliseconds
in one case.
And 20 times that length
in the other case.
And so this was a pretty big
difference not to be ignored.
So we wanted to look at
why that was going on.
So here, it's kind
of a dumb thing.
But the next the thing I did
was, well, let's take a look
at the configuration.
Maybe I did something stupid
that would have
caused this to happen.
Here's the deal.
In setup A, remember everything
is at the same
version number.
And it turns out this agent HAL
communication occurs over
a named pipe.
OK, whatever.
It turns out in setup B--
remember the client and the
server were at a different
version from the host, so the
server has to download some
shim code onto that
host so that
everybody can talk correctly.
It turns out that shim code
was communicating with the
hardware abstraction layer--
instead of over a named pipe--
it was communicating
over TCP/IP.
Now I have to give credit
to my colleague on this.
As soon as I showed him this
information, he hit a flash of
inspiration.
It turns out that when you're
using the named pipe and it
takes 10 milliseconds, the
reason that's different from
TCP/IP communication is because
of something called
Nagle's algorithm.
Nagle's algorithm basically
says, you want to accumulate
data before you send it so you
reduce the number of round
trips and the overhead
of creating a
connection, and whatever.
And the problem was this
was biting us.
Essentially, we were waiting
within that shim to collect
enough data to send it
back to that HAL.
And we were waiting fairly
needlessly, because what
happens is that this algorithm
waits for a
certain amount of time.
And then if it hasn't gotten
more data, it goes
ahead and sends it.
So we are basically stuck,
waiting for this time out to
occur before the data actually
got transferred.
And there's a very simple
way to get rid of that.
You just tell it, hey, don't
use Nagle's algorithm.
We don't care.
And that solves the
entire problem.
So the point is once you get rid
of that, the performance
is exactly the same.
It's a very simple configuration
setting.
But that's again, a situation
where somebody--
and in fact, I remember
asking why this
particular change was made.
And again, it was, well, we
didn't think it was going to
be a big deal.
And that ends up being, again,
a very bad way of doing
performance engineering.
So definitely, the lesson that
I learned here is just like
the lesson with 32-bit,
64-bit.
You might think that a little
change like this
doesn't mean anything.
But it really does.
And here, it's actually
important to understand the
entire stack end to end.
Because otherwise, you're never
going to be able to
figure out where the problem
actually was occurring.
I already alluded to a previous
situation where we
had a correctness problem,
which masked as
a performance problem.
In the previous case, it
was because I had a
limited thread pool.
And whenever I ran out of
threads, I'd queue everyting.
And at some point, I had a
correctness problem where I
kept killing threads and never
resurrecting them.
And so I ended up queuing
everything.
And everything went to pot.
Now let me talk about a
different situation.
Here I've got a poor little
customer, in fact that
customer was me.
I was powering on a
virtual machine.
Remember it goes to the server,
goes to host, powers
on the virtual machine,
tells me it's done.
Every other time I would do
this, it took five seconds,
which is pretty OK.
In comparison, every other time
I did it, it would take
about five minutes.
That's a pretty huge
expansion.
And if a customer called me
and said this, I would
basically be in deep
doggy do-do.
So it was important to try
to figure what was
actually going on here.
So why does powering on a
VM have such a variable
performance?
Well, the key here, again, is
to understand what's the end
to end path for things.
In this case, what I know is
that when you power on a
virtual machine, one of the
things you have to do is
allocate some space on
disk to write swap
information and whatever.
So one of the first places I
looked was I said, well, let
me understand how the disk is
performing in each of these
cases to try to figure
out what's going on.
It's a mixture of common sense
and knowing what's going on,
and then knowing
where to look.
So let me let you in
on a little secret.
In the real world, if you're
using some sort of disk, if
your disk latency is basically
10 milliseconds or less,
you're more or less golden.
That's not a problem.
If your latency is between 10
and 20 milliseconds, maybe
that's acceptable because you
have a complicated topology.
You're some multinational
corporation with sites
everywhere, whatever.
If your latency is getting to
the point where they're 50
milliseconds, then you probably
have to start worrying.
That's actually quite
a bit high.
If your latency is greater
than 51 seconds, that is
staggeringly bad.
In this chart, I show you
the latency versus time.
And what this chart shows you
is that every single time
step, it says in the last five
minutes, what was the highest
disk latency that I saw.
And remember our
rules of thumb.
10 milliseconds, good.
20 milliseconds, not so good.
50 milliseconds, not so good.
This one is 1,100
milliseconds.
That's like you could walk to
the disk, get the data, and
bring it back faster than what
it's actually doing.
That's when you've got
to call a priest.
OK.
That's horrible.
So this was the reason
that five
seconds versus five minutes.
So now the question is
why is this going on?
Why am I seeing such
unbelievably bad disk latency?
And remember, the title
of this case study was
"Correctness Impacts
Performance." So
let's take a look.
What I do here is I take a look
at all of the events that
are happening with respect
to that disk.
You're not going to
understand this.
It's some junk related
to our product.
But I'm going to circle
the relevant portion.
You'll notice a little
line that says
lost access to volume.
Here's the deal.
I send a request to the disk.
It turns out the disk is
connected over some channel to
some channel, a disk controller,
which is talking
to some disk.
It turns out, I kept losing
access to that disk.
Whenever I would lose access,
it would keep retrying.
And that's why ultimately,
yes, it would complete.
But it would take over a second
per disk request.
In the situations where I was
not seeing that loss of
connectivity, things were
occurring at the order of
milliseconds and my power-on
would take five seconds.
So the point here is that in
this case, it was actually a
correctness problem with
my controller.
And the controller would
basically flake out and not
talk to the disk properly.
And this manifested itself
in a performance problem.
Once I changed the disk
controller, performance
problems went away.
So if you're doing this kind
of debugging, sometimes you
have to eliminate--
I guess it's a Sherlock
Holmesism-- that you eliminate
the obvious and whatever's
left must be it.
A good example of this is my
ex-officemate, he used to ask
this question whenever he'd
interview somebody for VMware.
He'd say, OK, you have
a networking problem.
Where is the first
place you look?
And everybody that's coming
in with a grad degree or
whatever, they're like, I
would look at the stack.
I'd look at the CPU.
I'd look at a cache counters,
or whatever.
And my officemate would just
look at them and say, why
don't you just check the cable
and see if it's plugged in.
And surprisingly,
it's so dumb.
But when you're talking to
customers, they're like I
swear I did that.
I swear I did that.
Their swearing doesn't
necessarily mean anything,
unless it's directed at you.
So that's case study nine--
eight.
The last two case studies are
going to be specific to
virtualization.
And so what I'm going to do is
talk a little bit about how
the CPU scheduler works in the
VMware server class product.
And then I'll talk about the
last two case studies.
So actually how many of you
have used VMware before?
Just as a hand.
Thankfully, Saman has used it.
That's good.
So basically, the idea is that
you're multiplexing time on
the CPU between different
virtual machines that are
running on the CPU.
So what I show here is I
show ESX, which is our
server class product.
Basically, think of that
as the hardware.
So you're running virtual
machines on hardware.
That hardware has, in this
particular case,
four physical CPUs.
No problem.
You've got four physical CPUs.
And you want to run virtual
machines on this hardware.
So you've got one
virtual machine.
Well, that's fine.
There's four CPUs.
One virtual machine.
No problem.
Plenty of CPU to go around.
Now you got another one.
Still no problem.
They're not chained
to any given CPU.
And there's plenty of
CPU to go around.
No problem.
Same with three and four.
You got all these four
virtual machines.
It's not a one to one
correspondence in terms of CPU.
We don't work that way.
But there's plenty-- the point
is, there's plenty
of CPU to go around.
Now what happens, and when VMs
are basically available and
when there's hardware on which
they can run and they're using
the hardware, that's called
the run state.
So running means I'm golden.
I'm using the hardware.
Now, let's add another VM.
I put it in red, because this
poor VM, he wants to run.
But you'll see that every single
CPU is actually taken
up by another virtual machine.
So even if this virtual machine
wants to run, it can't.
It has to wait.
The time that it spends ready to
use the CPU, but unable to
use the CPU, because there's
no CPU available, that's
called ready time.
In some sense, it's kind
of the demand.
Ready plus signals down.
But anyway, the point is
it's sitting around
waiting to use the CPU.
But it can't, because other
people are using it.
So it has to wait its turn.
It waits its turn.
And eventually a VM, our ESX
scheduler is smart enough to
realize that it has to
fix the situation.
So it deschedules a VM-- in
this case, VM 1-- and goes
ahead and schedules that other
virtual machine that was
previously waiting.
Now predictably, the VM that's
now ready to run but can't is
in the ready state.
And the VM that formerly was
in the ready state is now
using the CPU.
So it's in the run state.
It's very happy.
The final thing that I should
point out is that VMs don't
have to be in the ready state.
They don't have to be either
using the CPU or
ready to use the CPU.
Some VMs are voluntarily
descheduled, because they have
nothing to do.
Some VMs are descheduled,
because they're waiting--
they're basically waiting
for an IO to complete.
And so they don't need
to use the CPU.
And that's what I
depict by VM6.
These are in what's called
the wait or idle states.
So hopefully, you now have
a fairly rudimentary
understanding of what our
CPU scheduler is doing.
Let's talk a little bit about
a very simple performance
problem related to this.
And I call this--
But It's Only a small
probe VM.
I'll explain what this
means in a minute.
Essentially, you've got two of
these hosts, two ESX hosts
that both want to run VMs.
And I've got a user, depicted
by the user icon.
And he's talking
to this one VM.
Let's call this VM
the vSphere VM.
Please pardon the
nomenclature.
It doesn't really matter.
But anyway, he's talking
to this vSphere VM
on one of the hosts.
Now, it turns out that that VM
that he's talking to, as I
depicted in the diagram, is
talking to another virtual
machine, which I have labeled
vSphere database.
So it turns out, this vSphere
VM is talking to a database
over what's called an
ODBC connection.
That doesn't matter.
Don't worry about that.
And it turns out that on that
other host where the database
virtual machine is running, we
have another virtual machine.
It's called the probe
virtual machine.
The job of that probe virtual
machine is to sniff any
traffic going into
the database.
So as I've said, the vSphere VM
communicates with the database.
This probe VM is monitoring any
traffic that's going to
that database virtual machine.
And therefore, as you can
imagine, the more traffic
that's being sent between this
vSphere VM and the database,
the more work that that
probe VM has to do.
Here was the complaint.
My colleague called me up, and
he said, hey, I'm having a
little bit of a problem
with my vSphere VM.
All of a sudden, it's completely
unresponsive.
So then I was like, OK, well,
this is kind of silly.
Let's try to figure out
what's going on.
So here's what I did.
I graphed various metrics, which
I just spoke about, the
used time and the ready
time, on this chart.
The time is on the x-axis.
And the y-axis is
in milliseconds.
In what I'm going to call the
land before time, the ready
time of the database.
So look at the circle on the--
let me think, you're--
on the left.
This is the ready time of that
database virtual machine.
Remember what we said,
when you're
accumulating ready time.
It means you really want
to use the CPU.
But you can't because all the
CPUs are already in use.
So it turns out that the first
thing that happened when my
colleague called and said I'm
having a problem, is I look at
this chart, which
is versus time.
And I said, let me guess.
Are you having a problem at
about such and such time,
which corresponds to the
middle of this chart?
And he said, yeah, that's when
I'm having a problem.
So you can tell that there are
two very clearly demarcated
regions here.
In the left, you can
see that this ready
time, it's around 12%.
Now if you're like me, a number
that has no context
means nothing.
So 12% means nothing.
However, what I'd like to point
out is that when things
got really bad, that number
spiked up to 20%.
So here's the deal.
I'm a database virtual
machine.
I want to use the physical
hardware.
I can use it about 90% of the
time, because my ready time's
about 12%, whatever.
But at some point, something
happens where I now can only
use it 80% of the time.
And it turns out that that
difference was enough to cause
this vSphere VM talking to this
database to be perturbed.
And that ultimately was the
customer's problem.
So the question is why.
And here is the reason.
Turns out, here's the deal.
Let's go back to the diagram
so I can explain this.
Remember that the vSphere VM
talks to the database VM.
Remember as well, that the more
traffic there is, the
more work the probe
VM has to do.
It turns out that what this user
did was at that critical
juncture, he started
a workload.
In starting that workload, he
caused a lot of traffic
between the vSphere VM and the
database, which therefore
caused a lot of work
by this probe VM.
Well, what's happening?
The probe VM and the database
VM are sharing the same
underlying CPUs.
So if one of them is running,
the other one can't.
And that's why we saw this
gentle increase in the amount
of ready time to vSphere
database.
Well, this has a cascading
effect, because it can't get
as much time to use a CPU.
Any request that goes to
it gets slowed down.
Where are the requests
coming from?
They're coming from
this vSphere VM.
Who's initiating
those requests?
It's this poor admin.
The bottom line is that this
admin is seeing poor
responsiveness because some
doofus put his probe VM on
some other host, because he
wanted to see what was going
on in the database.
In fairness, I was
that doofus.
But that's fine.
We needed that, because
we had to debug
other performance problems.
So the point is that one of
the things that's kind of
important in this particular
case is that whenever you
introduce any sort of
monitoring-- it's like a
Heisenberg thing-- it's going to
have a performance impact.
And understanding
that performance
impact is pretty key.
It might even shift where the
bottlenecks are in your system.
If your thing has a high cost
in terms of CPU, it might
shift the overhead of whatever's
running to the CPU
where it wasn't there before.
So it's kind of important to
understand what you're
monitoring and how you're
monitoring it.
OK.
We're almost done.
This was a really
curious problem.
We have a customer.
And a customer was performing
a load test on a server.
And in that load test, what they
would do is they would
just keep attaching clients
to that end server
and run some test.
At some point, they would
attach clients and their
workload suffered, their
workload performance suffered
even though there was no metric
that was saturated.
And so the question was why.
Why you keep adding clients,
nothing is saturated, but
performance suffers?
Well, this chart's kind
of an eyesore.
But let me explain it.
The first thing we do is we've
got some profiling
information.
On this chart, I show
two things.
In purple, I show CPU usage.
And in white, I show
disk latency.
As you can see from this
chart-- and the
y-axis is just 100%.
And they're both normalized.
As you can see at some point,
the CPU usage is steadily,
steadily increasing.
And at some point, the disk
latency takes over and gets to
be really large.
You can tell that, because up
until about 3/4 of the way in,
the disk latency hovers
around zero.
And all of a sudden, it
jumps much higher.
So my first instinct was to tell
the customer you've got a
disk problem.
Your disk latencies are
going over a cliff.
And that's why you're having
a performance problem.
Unfortunately, that's
not correct.
Why is that not correct?
It's not correct, because, yeah,
disk latency gets worse
at 4:00 PM.
It's because of swapping and
some other nonsense.
We know that.
However, the application latency
actually gets worse at
3:30, not at 4:00.
It's half an hour earlier.
So now the question is what's
going on that causes the
problem, even before disk
kicks in and gets to be
another problem.
This is where understanding
the difference in metrics
becomes pretty critical.
Now, I'm not expecting
very many people to
understand this chart.
But I will try to explain it.
What I do here is I show a
different chart, which
essentially shows CPU usage of
all the different virtual
machines and processes on
the underlying host.
Forget about what's in
most of this chart.
And just focus on what
I've circled.
I have two columns
shown there.
One column is called
percent used.
And one column is called
percent run.
You can think about it and
think, OK, well, I can imagine
used time means probably how
much time I'm using the CPU.
But then what is the runtime?
Isn't runtime the same thing,
because I'm using the CPU?
What's the difference?
This is actually the
critical problem.
It turns out, that when you talk
of a percent used time,
you're normalizing that to
the base clock frequency.
If I've got a three gigahertz
machine, I've normalized it to
three gigahertz.
However, we all live in the
era of power management.
It turns out this percent run,
which nobody understands, is
normalized to the clock
frequency at the
time you were running.
So if I did power management,
and I was only running at two
gigahertz for a certain amount
of time, percent
run captures that.
And so in this particular chart
what I'm showing is that
a bunch of virtual machines are
seeing used time different
from runtime.
And the runtime, which is
normalized to the clock
frequency of the time you're
using it, is actually greater
than used time, which suggests
that the user's actually using
power management.
And it turns out, that power
management was kicking in at
some point and causing their
application latency to go down
even though the CPU was
never saturated.
And in this case, when we went
back to the customer-- you
look at this chart, and you
instantly see, OK, I know that
because this is normalized and
this is normalized to that.
This is what's going on, you
have to first of all change
this parameter.
They changed it.
And they were unbelievably
happy.
It was pretty cool.
Now, I have to admit that
there's much more to this
story that I'm not
showing you.
Which I'm not allowed
to show you.
But it becomes a very
interesting thing.
But the point is it's very, very
important to understand
your metrics.
Here just understanding the
difference between runtime and
used time made all of the
difference in diagnosing this
customer's performance
related issue.
So I just pick a smattering
of ten random bugs.
And in each of them, I tried
to distill one kind of
conclusion you can get from
that particular thing.
Because all of you can read,
I'm not going to bother
repeating all of these things.
But anyway, here's
the first five.
And you all get the slides.
And here's the second five.
Oops.
I'll just keep that
up for a second.
And in order to conclude this
talk, let me just say that
it's very important to
avoid assumptions.
It's very tempting to
say well that's--
I'll give you a great example.
I used to interview people.
And I'd say, OK, you've
got a UI.
You've got a problem.
You have a UI.
And you click on something.
And it takes a long time.
Why is it taking a long time?
And the first thing they'd say,
well, I'd go and look
at-- this is literally,
not joking.
They'd say, well, I'd go to look
at the cache messages on
the server.
And I just looked them and I
said, how do you know the
client's not the problem?
Oh, the client's
not a problem.
And you base this on
what knowledge?
Don't use assumptions.
It's a very bad idea.
It's really important to
understand the entire system
that you're dealing with.
From the client to the server to
the hardware to the network
to the disk.
You have to understand all of
those different pieces,
because you have to understand
where to look.
And what's really onerous is
that-- it is not so much when
it's a problem in your code,
because you can be blamed for
making stupid mistakes--
it's when it's problems with
other people's code and you
spend a month looking at other
people's code, figuring out
what's the problem That's when
things are really kind of
irritating.
And especially when it's a
problem with hardware.
And I think the final bullet
I'll say is be persistent and
be thorough.
I don't have to tell you
how to be good workers.
So let's just blah,
blah, blah.
We're done.